[Music]
so as some of you may know I am a
stand-up comedian which means I tour
around the country from time to time
which means I stay in my fair share of
hotels I don't know if you guys have
stayed in a hotel recently and seen in
the bathroom they put up this sign that
says we care about the environment a
towel on the floor means please replace
a towel on the rack means I'll use it
again please be green reuse your towel I
don't know about you but whenever I see
something like this I always feel like
they're trying to get away with
something like they're not being
straight with me and I have the sassiest
reaction in my brain I read it I'm just
like alone in my bathroom like oh hell
no excuse
me you keep that big ass water fountain
with a giant waterfall running in the
lobby every night of the year including
Christmas Eve when no one's even at the
hotel and you want me to save
water how about this
wash my damn
towels this is the
bit every time someone in your hotel
just wants a side of fries from room
service you send it up with two
cellophane wrapped glasses of water and
entire bowl of sliced lemons disposable
salt and pepper shakers and three glass
bottles of mustard and you're asking me
to
conserve can I get an order of watch
myam
[Applause]
house and it's not just hotels this is
the best phrase kind for anything
whenever you're tired of getting
from something Watchman damn taals is
always there for you hey Airlines you
want me to pay an extra fee to sit in
the exit row but then you want my
assistance if the plane goes down so I'm
paying to help you
out how many frequent flyer miles does
it take to get you to wash my Pro
house
[Music]
uh Hey amusement
parks oh hey amusement
parks people with heart conditions can't
ride the roller coaster so you act like
you care but if they want to grab a
snack all you have for them is heart
healthy deep fried Snickers and funnel
cake you must be this tall to wash my D
[Applause]
down flying in the face of people that
think it's
over ah hey
Batman you won't kill the Joker because
you don't want to sink down to his level
so you just keep letting him murder
innocent people while you drive the
Batmobile down your High Road
how about this kill the damn Joker and
have Alfred wash my damn
[Applause]
down just like my dream last night so
watch my damn Cowboys we'll be right
back with je
[Applause]
[Music]
Bon